don't go University students in Hong
Kong are at the center of a protest
movement that's lasted three months it's
been a long summer holiday fighting for
democracy and greater rights but their
voices are as loud and strong as ever
and they want their battle to continue
[Music]
on day one of the new school year
thousands came from around Hong Kong to
the Chinese University known for its
political activism on this day for these
students there were no books in sight no
lectures to attend just a rallying call
to begin a strike for two weeks in that
time they want the government to meet
their demands including an independent
investigation into the crisis or they'll
intensify their campaign their
announcement came as state media in
China issued new warnings that the end
is coming for Hong Kong's protesters
there is no sign that threats coming
from mainland China are deterring the
youth of Hong Kong if anything it
appears to be having the opposite effect
they're becoming emboldened more
determined to achieve their goals
organizers say around 10,000 secondary
school students decided to join the
strike some who have joined street
protests over the past three months say
political awareness is growing among
schoolchildren in the past they don't
really care about political they may
think eating drinking or playing is more
important but what really makes me feel
very touched is in the past three months
many often really start caring about the
political
the government criticized the decision
to allow schools colleges and
universities to be dragged into the
crisis schools should not be used as
places for raising political demands or
trying to exercise pressure on the
government on political issues we would
like to keep schools as a calm peaceful
and orderly place for students to to
study representatives of workers from 20
sectors also called for a two-day strike
while thousands gathered in the city to
protest workers at Queen Mary Hospital
formed a chain to show their support but
it's in the universities where the power
base of the protest movement can be
found striking students have placed
their education on hold for two weeks
they say their books can wait because
the future they're fighting for is more
important Wayne hey al Jazeera Hong Kong